our other top story ccsd's five-day
pause of fish lands tomorrow when
students return to the classroom 8 news
now reporter sally jaramillo spoke to
some teachers who don't feel this pause
was long enough sally
kirsten and christian ccsd says come
tomorrow schools like this one will open
up and there will be no virtual classes
now many of the teachers i spoke with
today tell me they have mixed feelings
some adding they feel those five days
were not enough
i think it was a start
i think there's more work to be done
luanne wagner is the senior social
studies teacher at clark high school
she's been teaching for 24 years now and
says ccsd needs to be listening to
administrators teachers and
students back at the beginning when we
were we were out and then we finally
went back in i know that there were some
schools especially elementary where they
did have the
plexiglass up
for
the students while some teachers still
have that in place there are others like
her who never had it in their classroom
i know that there's many teachers who
are concerned because
you know they have autoimmune immune
diseases there are some teachers who
have underlying health issues what's
happening at my school is not happening
at other schools steve short elementary
teacher kristen nigro agrees we're
talking about kindergarten compared to
you know uh you know high school seniors
i mean that's two different animals
right there we were already a skeleton
crew and with the staff not being able
you know to come back because of the
backup in the health line as well as you
know positive cases because the omicron
variant
i mean we were we were really having a
hard time staying afloat but one thing's
for sure from both teachers they don't
want to teach outside of the classroom
let us teach
the five-day pause was due to staffing
concerns and safety of the teachers and
students now for now reporting live from
robert e lake elementary school sally
caramillo live local now